uh the spectator we published a very
good column a couple years ago by cosmo
landsman
uh wonderful journalist uh who's one of
those journalists who i particularly
love because he always writes columns
you think oh my god i can't believe that
somebody wrote that i'm allowed to be
published that's fantastic
he wrote a very funny column about why
sex with right-wing women is a lot
better than having sex with left-wing
women
and one of my favorite details of this
was that during sex
with somebody who said worked at the
guardian
at some point during the encounter he um
used the phrase um you love it you
[ __ ]
[Laughter]
you and i might think that using the
term
you love it you [ __ ] to a guardian
employee
is treading in risky terrain anyhow it
struck cosmo as being the
mott zeus at the time and um he came out
with it
she immediately immediately apparently
immediately stopped
proceedings and made it clear that
uh something along the lines of just
because we're having sex
doesn't mean that you can degrade me as
a woman
and uh cosmo was sort of you know stuck
in a
tricky position here and i think said
something along the lines of
no no sure can i start again
though can i get back in and uh
and i don't know exactly how it finished
maybe it didn't
but anyhow the point is is this he said
he said this is a nightmare this is the
sort of thing that happens with
left-wing women
and right-wing women an awful lot more
fun in the sack
and this is provable and i'm
i don't think we have pie charts graphs
or something we can provide this but i
hear it please
i hear this story all the time and i
think i think it's um
it's uh it's definitely the case uh and
the gay scene
uh uh you you wouldn't want uh you
wouldn't want to
date an extinction rebellion protester
you you wouldn't want that you wouldn't
want to be
um you wouldn't want to be with somebody
who's
who you had to weigh i mean i'm not even
just talking about the sex i'm talking
about the fact that
you wouldn't want to be with somebody
who you were forever having to check
what you were saying with and who might
instead of
the normal thing most sort of normal
people it's not even a left right thing
if somebody says something that they
sort of don't agree with they say well
i don't agree with that and then you say
that's interesting why and then they
tell you
that's a normal human interaction that
is a relationship
you argue about the kids name oh i want
to call it alyssia no no i don't like
alyssia my aunt used to be called alyssa
she was a [ __ ]
yes exactly or just you know things like
you know i've always had this
i've always thought this and and then
you know you is one of the nice things
about relationships you just
discover the other person discover the
oddity of the other person quite often
and
you know and that's all that's all good
you wouldn't want to be with somebody
nobody should want to be with somebody
who's policing all the time
around the boundaries to make sure that
you're exactly in lockstep with what
you're meant to believe
today it seems who would want that it
seems bizarre to me
especially that 69 is quite a popular
sex position it seems bizarre to me that
you can have seen
someone's [ __ ] inches from your eyes
and
not be allowed to call them a [ __ ] it's
like look
we have i agree it's outrageous
look the sex police need to steam in
and and have a have a discussion as i've
always said by the way i mean the
the hardest one on that one is is how
the rules are like that
and uh what's the name e.l james i don't
say pdj
pdj 50 shades of grey woman uh that
sells by the bucket load i mean that
i think i say that a man is a crowd
somewhere that's a very weird i mean
you know it's a very weird thing that
nobody bothered to have out that at the
same time as
you know all of the increasing policing
about relations between sexes were going
on
women were buying hardcore s
m fiction porn by the truckload
i mean it definitely wasn't all men
buying that you know it sold it sold
like more copies
than the next four top selling of the
top five books
ever right in like combined instances
exactly and so and all of this is so
damn
interesting yes it's so interesting
and like nobody talks about it or can
have the conversation about it
we are right now
[Music]